okay okay we're in
okay it's on okay thank you
thank you so much oh let me give you
some bashish bushish
[Music]
i was told jeddah is more liberal and
more
open and that was a great example
so i walked in the hotel i was i was
pretending to take footage of the hotel
and i asked her neva could i turn the
camera around and she was
totally cool with it and she was great
right just big open smile
and so it does feel more open here feels
more liberal and it feels
very diverse
[Music]
thank you my friend thank you
you're telling me
[Music]
cruise around jeddah saudi arabia and
we're lucky enough to have
abdullah as her
faithful god very fascinating place
very much mixed up very
cultural in the sense that there we just
saw a group of
filipino bikers indonesians
indians pakistanis syrians i think there
are two narratives
for people that don't know about saudi
which is pretty much everyone
i think the two narratives of one is
everyone's on a camel
okay and it's just sand and the other is
everyone's just dripping in oil wealth
and super rich yeah what do you what do
you think it is
it's neither both i mean uh they are
just
normal like every place
you have the middle class the upper
class
the lower class your income tax is what
what do you pay for income tax zero the
income tax
the whole live music thing here
just started right well people here used
to go out and
go out after the country to attend live
concerts
okay but now uh they
are welcoming these concerts here
yeah they they invited many uh artists
including uh
nicki minaj but she didn't come
janet jackson she came he said okay one
thing
i've liked about saudi is
it's not a drinking culture at least on
the outside so people are
they're entertaining themselves in a
different way in the west quite often
the entertainment is revolved around our
alcohol
bars i'm not a drinker i quit four years
ago
four or five years ago yeah man
no judgment no judgment against drinking
it's just
nice to be an environment where the the
focal point
is not drinking exactly
morning brother
[Music]
salam
when does this fill up when do these
places get busy
weekend nights nights yeah yeah and also
today
it can be after the prayer
[Music]
okay so you're you're from riyadh
originally but you live in and
when did it start where like you could
come out here alone as a woman
drink your coffee you're working on a
spreadsheet when did that start
happening
here i believe it starts happening
way before i start doing it the idea of
me
going out um without having
a kid that job or anything
i was i was scared to do that because i
thought that
you know negative things will happen to
me actually when i start doing it like
nothing happens
you know it's like i am i'm feeling
something that
is not here for you to to do what you
want
and let others do what they want right
so is it
your very your younger twenties right
yeah
okay so is it a very exciting time for
the youth right now it's really really
really exciting yeah
so there are lots of opportunities you
know yeah
maybe in your country or in your own you
know
uh in your communities you hear about
all of these people who
who started things you know who are the
ones to do
the first one to do this or the first
one to do that right
you know that happened maybe in your
dad's generation but
in our case this will happen in our
relationship so i get to be the first
one to do something
i get to be the one who's changing the
narrative you know
wow that's exciting someone said that
saudi arabia is a place
where people who know about it don't
speak about it and people who speak
about it
they really don't know about it
[Music]
they used to walk from the port way down
there yeah all the way up here all the
way to mecca
yeah which is how far makkah is like
driving one hour so you can imagine
in the heat this is this is no joke here
people are living in these are now right
now
not all the buildings right some of the
buildings
this whole old town old city
is just an adventure of going down
different
windy alleyways labyrinths and then
seeing
that beautiful
[Music]
happy birthday
huh
it's like two different worlds
completely yeah
from the mega shopping malls and like
all the modern coffee shops
yeah and this is old world it feels like
this is where
everything started abdullah will not let
me pay for anything he's paid for
lunch desserts dinner last night
he's very sturdy he's actually you're
more stubborn than me
you're more stubborn than me bro i'm
ready i'm pretty stubborn
because i've tried to pay it's in the
culture here though right like
an arab would it be is it an arab thing
or is it a saudi thing
no it's an arab thing right like the
guest does not pay for things
yeah to some degree yes yeah
so prophet um because this was available
in medina where
you live so he used to clean his teeth
so
every period of the prayer he used it
every prayer he uses what do i do just
chew on it
yeah so you do like this on your thumbs
feels good
[Music]
that's an interesting combination
mall culture is going off here
and so on the hot days in jeddah
which is well every day it's hot
midday nobody's on the streets
everybody's in these mega malls
one of the reasons i wear this is i need
protection from the sun
and it's actually it's actually quite
comfortable it's like way better than a
baseball cap which i don't like
and another reason is
well it confuses people here so if i if
i go without
i just look like some military american
guy
which i'm not i am american but i'm not
in the military
but if i wear this it confuses people
and so they think i'm either from egypt
syria or from the balkans
yeah it's it's it's like very
interesting how i'm received with this
versus without like positive both ways
but from a different
different look hey
[Music]
here's a little cultural detail as they
close
businesses for prayer time i'm trying to
get into this coffee shop
i think it's like 20 30 minutes at a
time
and then once the prayer time is over
everything opens green coffee
and we roast the coffee ourselves so we
get from
different origins latin america africa
uh i mean we get from yemen as well does
yemen have good coffee
it has one of the best coffees really
yeah in the world and we roast the
coffee and this is
our own brand it's not a franchise or
anything nobody knew
how it's going to be three years ago but
now i mean it's everyone is quitting
their jobs and they're starting
businesses
whether it was you know coffee shops
services
you're telling me okay a lot of the
expats would move to saudi
and go in their compounds yeah close
compound closed area
they don't blend in with the locals
because many of them
when they came here they get scary
or dangerous thoughts that they are not
friendly they are
don't like foreigners like that right
like these things so they came here
scared so they don't want to blame them
right
okay so they afraid of blending in with
people but
some of them when they when they get in
touch with some locals
they get a good feedback but they're
very few right
should i should i be scared
[Music]
mubarak what do you think of all these
changes there's so many changes so
quickly here
very nice very good very good i'm agree
with this
it's it's must be before that
times yeah before that 25 years
because my youth
times without this thing yeah
okay we traveled aboard to buying
something we didn't find it here now
right
it change every day and you don't know
what's coming i don't know what's coming
but i'm sure
we are going to the right way to the
right track
very good to get people chance
to know about saudi arabia to know about
islam about real islam
yeah you know sometimes
[Music]
in another countries some people
make something effect for islam
and people who they know about this
thing yeah this is
islam but it's not yeah when you come to
saudi arabia you find
the people you talk to the people yeah
you
as you think now you also have in saudi
arabia
yeah you you will change your image
about saudi arabia
for sure and you will use word of mouth
for the people
thank you my friend hope to meet you
again
inshallah
[Music]
[Applause]
let's check it out
[Music]
uh aerospace administration and
operations okay
and it was a great experience actually
it's very very different from here yeah
so
you had to know the culture there
experience like with the people
[Music]
how does it feel it's perfect
yeah i want to go back there yeah you
want to visit to visit
yeah for sure you're happy with how
saudi is right yeah
for sure we're getting like very
modernized
you're a pro thank you brotherhood
welcome
it's my second country yeah yeah yeah i
feel that
son we've been chatting we've had a
great conversation
so you in public you always wear a full
abaya
and that's a choice yeah this is my
choice yeah
cool this is my choice that choice my
family
can't it's my choice this is
you're a doctor yeah i thought you were
a lawyer
yeah and a doctor yeah wow
a superwoman professor
professor-in-law and a doctor what kind
of doctor
[Music]
eye doctor wow
it's been a very rewarding experience
and i've met
so many cool warm people and i thought
before it would be sort of hard because
tourists were just allowed here for the
first time so i thought maybe it'd be
closed and hard
but it was open and warm
and very educational so
thank you thank you saudi people thank
you welcome to saudia
thank you
[Music]
you